[S01] 你知道吗
[S01] 呃，著名物理学家理查德·费曼在1985 年的时候曾经说过一句就是非常发人深省的话
[S02] 哦，1985 年，他说什么了
[S01] 他说啊，计算机的主要功能并不是传统意义上的计算，它们主要是归档系统
[S02] 哇，这句话放在今天听起来简直怎么说呢，就像是高维度的预言一样精准
[S01] 没错，你现在可能正拿着手机滑动屏幕给朋友的动态点个赞，或者呃在地图上搜索附近的餐厅，甚至在电商APP里疯狂下单
[S02] 对，数据像是那种永不停歇的洪流嘛
[S01] 就是说，但是你有没有想过，当你把这些海量的行为轨迹交给这些 app 的时候，他们到底是怎么在浩如烟海的那个数字档案里，瞬间真的是不费吹灰之力地瞬间，把你想要的信息给找出来的
[S02] 嗯，这背后其实隐藏着一套极其精密，同时又充满妥协和智慧的系统
[S01] 所以在这次深度的知识探索中，我们要带你潜入数据库的最底层，带你一探究竟。
[S01] 我们的任务呢，就是为你拆解那些让当今数字世界得以运转的核心引擎
[S02] 确实，我们要聊的内容蛮多的
[S01] 对，我们会从传统的OLTP，也就是 Online Transaction Processing，一路聊到现代的大数据分析 OLAP，最后呃还要带你冲浪，去看看极具未来感，能够理解人类意图的AI 向量搜索
[S02] 如果我们把它和更大的图景联系起来看，
[S02] 作为开发者或者仅仅是一个充满好奇心的学习者，你了解这些底层机制，其实不仅仅是为了看懂复杂系统的运作
[S01] 那还有什么更深层的原因吗
[S02] 更重要的是，它能让你在面对如今这个信息过载的世界时，真正理解这些工具背后的权衡哲学。毕竟没有任何一种技术是完美的，
[S02] 它们都在物理法则和业务需求之间做出了极致的妥协
[S01] 没错，
[S01] 软件工程里从来就没有银弹。那为了理解这些复杂的数据库，我们要先从最简单，呃，最原始的存储方法讲起，那就是追加写入，Append Only Log
[S02] 对，这是最基础的
[S01] 你可以把它想象成，就在你日记本的最后一页不断地写新字，
[S01] 这种方式写入的速度简直快得飞起，因为系统根本不需要思考该把数据放在哪儿，闭着眼睛往后加就行了
[S02] 是的，这就是所有日志结构数据的起点，但是问题也随之而来呀
[S01] 找起来很麻烦，对吧
[S02] 没错，
[S02] 写入是快了，可当你需要查找某一条特定的记录时，你就惨了，你必须从日记本的第一页开始，一页一页地往下翻，直到找到为止
[S01] 天呐，那得多慢啊
[S02] 在算法术语里，这叫做O(N) 的复杂度。随着你日记本越来越厚，数据量翻倍，你查找的时间也要成比例地翻倍
[S01] 好的，
[S01] 让我们来拆解一下，为了解决这个找的问题呢，数据库的索引诞生了。世界上最流行的两种查找方式，
[S01] 其实就像是两种截然不同的，呃，整理衣柜的哲学
[S02] 哦，整理衣柜，这个比喻挺新鲜的
[S01] 第一种叫做B 树，B-Tree，它就像是一个有着无数个精细抽屉的传统大文件柜。每次你有了新数据，也就是买了一件新衣服，你都要拉开特定的那个抽屉，把里面的旧衣服拿出来，把新衣服塞进去
[S02] 在专业术语里，这就叫做就地更新，也就是 In-Place Update
[S01] 对，就地更新
[S02] 呃，我觉得你这个比喻非常贴切。B 树从1970 年诞生以来，可以说是经受住了漫长的时间考验，它把数据库分成了固定大小的页，或者说数据块
[S01] 比如多大呢
[S02] 比如PostgreSQL默认一页是8KB，而MySQL默认是16KB。B 树的查找非常稳定，不管数据有多少，一棵拥有几百个分支的B 树，通常只需要三到四层就能存下海量数据，查找深度的复杂度只有O(log N)
[S01] 哇，只要三四层，那确实很快
[S02] 是的，但是为了保证数据的绝对安全，它必须引入一个机制，叫做预写日志，也就是 WAL
[S01] 等等，我这里有个疑问，呃，你刚才说我们要把数据写进那特定的一页，或者说抽屉里，但是如果在写这一页的过程中，呃，突然断电了，这一页的数据岂不是损坏了
[S02] 完全正确，这就是预写日志存在的原因。
[S02] 在B 树真正去更新那个8KB的抽屉之前，它必须先在一个只追加写入的日志文件里，把你要做的修改记录下来
[S01] 啊，也就是说先打个草稿，确认一下
[S02] 没错，确认记录好了，它再去更新那个抽屉
[S01] 这听起来有点矛盾啊，我们都知道磁盘IO通常是数据库的性能瓶颈嘛，如果写磁盘这么昂贵，为什么把一份数据写两次，一次写日志，一次写抽屉，反而能被业界广泛接受呢
[S02] 这就是一个非常核心的工程洞察。虽然写了两次，但这两次写入的性质是完全不同的
[S01] 怎么个不同法
[S02] 往预写日志里写，那是顺序写入，就像我们刚才说的写日记，这在物理磁地上是非常非常快的，几乎不需要寻址
[S01] 那写抽屉呢
[S02] 而更新那8KB的抽屉是随机写入，磁底磁体硬盘磁头要到处跳来跳去找位置，这非常慢。而且在B 树里，有时候哪怕你只改了几个字节，它也必须把整个8KB的页重新写一遍
[S01] 天呐，就改几个字也要重写一整页
[S02] 对，这就是著名的写放大，Write Amplification
[S01] 原来如此，顺序写入极快，所以多写一次日志作为保险，这个时间成本其实是可以接受的。但是如果B 树的这种就地更新会导致随机写入，还会引发写放大，那最极致的解决思路是不是干脆放弃整理啊
[S02] 你的意思是
[S01] 就像我们一开头说的日记本那样，
[S01] 永远只在最后面顺序写入啊，但是呃我们要怎么解决它查找慢的死穴呢
[S02] 你的推导非常精准，这就是我们要探讨的另一种佛系，佛系，它的超级挑战者LSM 树，也就是日志结构合并树
[S01] 这个名字听起来很硬核啊
[S02] 如果顺着你的思路，LSM 树就像是你根本不去实施整理抽屉，你每天回家，先把所有的文件或者新衣服一股脑全扔进内存里的一个暂存箱
[S01] 暂存箱，在数据库里叫什么
[S02] 在数据库里，这个暂存箱叫做内存表，Mem-Table
[S01] 然后呢，
[S01] 暂存箱总会满的吧，不可能一直扔里面
[S02] 等内存表塞满了之后，
[S02] 系统会在后台把它们一次性打包成一个包裹。注意在打包的时候，它会在内存里把所有的东西按字母顺序排好，变成一个整整齐齐的不可变的包裹
[S01] 哦，不可变的包裹叫什么
[S02] 叫做SSTable，然后它一次性顺序写入到磁地仓库里。这种只追加不修改的方式，可以说是把磁底的写入速度榨干到了极致
[S01] 但是如果LSM 树一直在往仓库里扔新的SSTable包裹，而这些包裹里不仅有新数据，还可能就是有旧版本的数据，甚至是代表删除的墓碑记录
[S02] 对，会有这些过时或者标记删除的数据
[S01] 那当我真正需要找一个特定数据的时候，难道我要把仓库里所有不可变的包裹都翻一遍？这听起来依然是一场查找效率的噩梦啊
[S02] 这里令人着迷的是，LSM 树的设计者早就预判了你的担忧，他们引入了一个终极武器来解决这个读取瓶颈，那就是布隆过滤器
[S01] 布隆过滤器，愿闻其详
[S02] 它是一种极速的概率数据结构。在我们的原材料中，一位名叫Bisbock的贡献者分享了一个非常硬核的细节
[S01] 什么细节
[S02] 一个几兆字节的SSTable包裹，如果你给它配上一个包含一百万个数据位的布隆过滤器，你猜这个布隆过滤器占多大空间
[S01] 一百万个位，怎么着也得几十兆吧
[S02] 不，它大约只需来占用极小的零点一二五MB空间
[S01] 真的假的，一百万个位才占零点一二五MB，这么微小的体积能干什么呀
[S02] 它可以瞬间回答你一个至关重要的问题。当你拿着一个查询去问布隆过滤器时，它如果说不在，那这个数据就绝对不在这包裹里，你连磁盘都不用碰，
[S02] 直接跳过这个包裹
[S01] 哦，直接过滤掉了，那如果它说在呢
[S02] 如果它说在，那意思是它很可能在这里，你再去真正读取磁盘上的包裹，这就完美过滤掉了绝大多数无效的磁盘读取
[S01] 哇，所以本质上这是一种精妙的资源置换啊，
[S01] 设计者是用极其廉价微小的内存空间买到了极其昂贵的磁盘读取时间，从而抹平了LSM 树读取效率低下的短板
[S02] 总结得非常到位
[S01] 这里才是真正有趣的地方。既然B 树和LSM 树各有千秋，
[S01] 一个读取稳定，
[S01] 一个写入极快，那这到底是谁主沉浮呢？其实这不仅仅是软件算法在神仙打架，这更是物理硬件层面的妥协
[S02] 没错，我们必须要往下看一层了
[S01] 对，我们必须看看承载这些数据的土地，也就是我们电脑和SERVER里的固态硬盘，SSD
[S02] 硬件的物理特性是无法违背的。我们要深刻理解刚才提到的顺序写入和随机写入在SSD上的不同命运。B 树的那种就地更新产生的随机写入，对于SSD来说简直就是一场灾难
[S01] 为什么？如果你曾经在配置云服务器或者挑选数据库实力时，面对高并发写入的场景犹豫不决，这段底层逻辑应该能完美解答你的困惑
[S02] 是的
[S01] SSD明明没有了老式机械硬盘那种转动的物理磁头，到处跳跃写入应该也很快才对啊
[S02] 虽然没有了机械寻道时间，但SSD有一个极其致命的物理怪癖，它可以按较小的页来写入数据，但如果要擦除或者覆盖数据，它必须按非常大的块儿来整体擦除
[S01] 块，Block
[S02] 对，当B 树到处乱写，反复修改同一块区域时，SSD内部就会产生大量失效的碎片。为了清理这些碎片存储空间，SSD的主控芯片必须在后台疯狂地做垃圾回收，也就是GC
[S01] 就是把有效数据搬走，然后清空一整块
[S02] 没错
[S01] 这就解释了为什么有些数据库在写入量极大的时候会突然卡顿，因为底层的硬盘正在手忙脚乱地搬运数据，不仅抢占了传输带宽，还会极大地加速闪存芯片的物理磨损
[S02] 非常正确。反观LSM 树，它永远是一次性把排好序的大包裹顺序写入新的空白区域，根本不需要怎么做垃圾回收，
[S02] 对SSD极其友好
[S01] 正是如此。所以在高并发写入的大数据场景下，LSM 树成为了当之无愧的王者
[S02] 确实是这样
[S01] 既然磁盘这么麻烦，又要管垃圾回收，又要管擦除块的，而且现在内存RAM的价格越来越便宜了，
[S01] 我们为什么不干脆就是一不做二不休，把所有数据都塞进内存里
[S02] 你是说像VODDB或者REDS那样
[S01] 对啊，全内存数据库，完全抛弃磁盘不就直接起飞了吗
[S02] 这是一个非常自然的想法，但这里有一个极其反直觉的洞察，
[S02] 全内存数据库之所以快，真正的原因并不单纯是因为它们不需要从磁盘读取数据
[S01] 啊，不是因为省了读磁盘的IO时间吗？毕竟内存比磁盘快了几万倍啊
[S02] 如果仅仅是读取，
[S02] 传统的磁盘数据库，只要内存足够大，操作系统本身也会把热点数据缓存在内存里，
[S02] 读取时照样不需要碰磁盘
[S01] 哦，对，有缓存。那全内存数据库真正快在哪里呢
[S02] 它们真正实现降维打击的秘密在于省去了数据翻译与序列化的时间
[S01] 数据翻译是什么概念
[S02] 在传统数据库里，数据在内存里的鲜活状态和最终要写进磁盘里的特定格式，比如我们前面说的那8KB的页是完全不同的
[S01] 嗯，格式不一样
[S02] 为了把内存数据存进磁盘，
[S02] 系统的CPU必须耗费大量的算力去计算页边界，
[S02] 处理指针序列化数据，最后打包成块
[S01] 所以全面内存数据库就不用干这些活了
[S02] 没错，全面内存数据库因为确信数据永远待在内存里，
[S02] 直接砍掉了所有这些为了适配磁盘而存在的庞大CPU开销，它打破的其实是CPU计算的瓶颈，而不仅仅是IO瓶颈
[S01] 原来如此，搞半天瓶颈不仅在磁盘，还在CPU的打包运算上，这才是内存数据库真正的魔法
[S02] 是的，这是一个认知上的飞跃
[S01] 好了，
[S01] 我们前面聊的这些，不管是B 树，LSM 树还是内存数据库，
[S01] 其实都是在解决OLTP，也就是Online事物处理的问题。
[S01] 本质上是为了在茫茫人海中快速找到并更新某一个人的具体信息
[S02] 这是日常交易的核心
[S01] 但是刚才讲的，无论是找一个人还是修改一条订单，我们处理的都是单一的高频操作。如果视角变了呢
[S02] 怎么个变法
[S01] 比如，
[S01] 一个跨国零售商，他不想找具体的某个人，他想分析二零二四年购买过婴儿纸尿裤的人在星期几更喜欢顺手买几瓶啤酒
[S02] 哈哈，这可是个经典的大数据分析场景，也就是OLAP，Online分析处理。如果你还用传统的行式存储来查这个问题，
[S02] 系统绝对会崩溃的
[S01] 确实会崩溃。这就好比，呃，有一本记录了一百个特征的全国人口普查名册。
[S01] 传统的行式存储就像是标准的通信录，把一个人的姓名、年龄、住址、购物习惯全部写在同一行
[S02] 对，一行一条记录
[S01] 如果你想统计所有人的年龄，
[S01] 系统必须把每一页从头读到尾，把成本上千个你根本不关心的多余信息全读进内存，哪怕你只上看年龄这一项
[S02] 太浪费资源了
[S01] 而列式存储呢，就像是把所有人的年龄单独抽了出来，重新装订成了一本极薄的小册子，你只需要花几秒钟读完这份薄薄的册子就行了
[S02] 这个比喻极其精准，这就是为什么像Snowflake、BigQuery这样的云数据仓库，底层都采用了列式存储，
[S02] 它们只从磁盘上精准加载查询所需要的列，比如商品名和星期几，其他几十个无关的列看都不看
[S01] 那节省的磁盘IO绝对是指数级的
[S02] 是的，这就引出了一个重要的问题。既然把列单独抽出来已经这么快了，
[S02] 我们还能在极限之上让它变得更快吗
[S01] 工程师们的执念肯定是能，他们是怎么做到的
[S02] 答案是通过两种底层的性能魔法，位图编码和向量化处理
[S01] 位图编码
[S02] 想象一下，
[S02] 一个超市有几亿条销售记录，但商品种类可能只有十万种。
[S02] 在商品这一极长的一列里，啤酒这个词可能重复出现了几百万次
[S01] 嗯哼
[S02] 我们完全可以把这一列变成一堆位图。如果你这一行买的是啤酒，这个位就是一，否则就是零。因为大部分记录不是啤酒，所以这个位图里全是零，非常稀疏
[S01] 哇，等于把漫长的文字变成了由一和零组成的极度压缩的二进制细长条，这不仅极大地压缩了体积，还直接迎合了CPU的胃口，对吧
[S02] 没错，就这是向量化处理发挥威力的地方。当你要找星期五且买了啤酒的所有记录时，
[S02] 对数据库不需要像人类一样一行一行去比对字眼
[S01] 那它怎么比
[S02] 它只需要把啤酒的位图和星期五的位图调出来，
[S02] 直接扔给CPU,让CPU做一次底层的按位与运算，也就是AND
[S01] 直接是二进制
[S02] 对，现代CPU对这种二进制位运算的处理速度是闪电般的，
[S02] 一个SIMD指令就能同时处理一大批零和一，瞬间就能筛选出两边都是一的精准结果
[S01] 我的天，从寻找一根针变成了通过二进制直接称重整座草堆，这简直是暴力的美学啊
[S02] 确实非常暴力且优雅
[S01] 不过刚才讲的，无论是找一个人，还是统计几亿人的购物习惯，本质上都是在处理精确的结构化数据，也就是非黑即白，一就是一，零就是零
[S02] 是的，
[S02] 传统数据库就擅长干这个
[S01] 但回到我们开场说的，在这个数字宇宙里，
[S01] 我们人类的行为和意图往往是模糊的。比如你向客服机器人提问，或者在地图上找地方，
[S01] 传统的这种依靠精确匹配的B 树或者列式存储，
[S01] 面对这种需求岂不是束手无策了
[S02] 你触及到了目前数据库领域最惊动人心的前沿。对于地图上的二维空间数据，
[S02] 我们有二树这样的专门引索。对于拼写错误，
[S02] 我们有倒排索引或者莱文斯坦自动机
[S01] 那如果意图更复杂呢
[S02] 如果我们想让系统真正理解人类模糊的意图行为意图，这就必须引入AI示意搜索与向量嵌入，也就是Vector Embeddings
[S01] 这个Vector Embeddings这个车，随着大模型爆发简直是火出圈了，它到底是怎么颠覆传统数据库查找方式的
[S02] 简单来说，它把所有的信息，无论是文章、图片，还是人类的自然语言提问，通过神经网络通通转化成了多维空间中的一个坐标点
[S01] 一个坐标点
[S02] 对，也就是一个包含了成百上千个浮点数的向量
[S01] 你能用原材料里的例子具体说明一下这个坐标点是怎么体现出意义的吗
[S02] 当然，假设我们有一个多维的羽翼空间，关于农业的维基百科页面，
[S02] 它的坐标可能是零点一，零点二二，零点一一
[S01] 嗯，三个维度，这只是个比方，对吧
[S02] 对，而关于蔬菜的页面，它的坐标可能是零点一三，零点一九，零点二四。
[S02] 你会发现这两个坐标在数学的高维空间里离得非常近
[S01] 那如果不相关的呢
[S02] 如果你看关于计算技术行星模式的页面，它的坐标可能是零点八二，零点三九，负的零点七四，它在空间里的位置就跟前面两个离了十万八千里
[S01] 哇，我彻底明白了，这就完美解释了为什么当你在一个APP的帮助文档里搜索如何关闭我的账户时，
[S01] 系统能精准地弹出一个标题叫取消订阅的页面
[S02] 没错，就是这个原理
[S01] 虽然这两个词在字面上有任何重合，
[S01] 传统的精确搜索绝对搜不出来，但它们在AI构建的多维空间里，
[S01] 坐标距离是非常非常接近的
[S02] 完全正确，但是这就给数据库带来了前所未有的工程挑战
[S01] 什么挑战
[S02] 在几亿个甚至几十亿个这种拥有上千维度的向量大海里，你要怎么快速计算并找到离你提问最近的那个坐标？如果我们用最笨的平面索引挨个去算距离，
[S02] 那延迟将是不可接受的
[S01] 对啊，怎么可能每次搜索都把上亿个点遍历一遍，
[S01] 那算法工程师是怎么解决这个高维索引难题的呢
[S02] 他们发明了诸如HNSW分层可拿为搞小世界，或者IVF倒排文件，这样的近似最近邻算法
[S01] HNSW听起来很高级啊
[S02] 我们可以把HNSW详细展开一下。想象你要自驾去一个完全陌生的偏远村庄
[S01] 好的，我现在拿着拿岛准备出发
[S02] 你不会一开始就在极其复杂的乡间路上瞎转，那就像是底层包含了上亿个向量的密体图，你会迷失在计算量里的
[S01] 那我该怎么走
[S02] 速，这是最高层，这里的节点极少，但跨度极大。你能迅速跨越半个国家，找到离那个村庄最近的高速出口
[S01] 然后我下高速进入下一层
[S02] 没错，你下到省道县道，每一次向下穿透层级，
[S02] 道路网络也就是节点变得更密集，但你要搜索的地理范围已经大幅小小了
[S01] 哦，范围小小了，就算节点密点也不怕了
[S02] 最后，你进入乡道，锁定哪个村庄，通过这种从稀疏的高层逐级向下跳跃的方式，
[S02] 系统完全不需要对比图谱里的每一个点，就能跨越维度大海，急速锁定离你寓意最接近的目标区域
[S01] 太巧妙了，
[S01] 那么这一切到底意味着什么？
[S01] 让我们稍微停下来回味一下，在这次深度的知识探索中，
[S01] 我们带你从最原始的日记本追加写入开始，
[S01] 走过了像精密文件柜一样的B 树
[S02] 我们还体验了为了榨干固态硬盘性能，用布隆过滤器换取读取时间的LSM 树
[S01] 我们也看到了为了突破CPU计算瓶颈而舍弃磁盘打包开销的内存数据库
[S02] 以及领略了用位图和底层的算术魔法去瞬间撑起整座数据超多的列式存储
[S01] 最后，
[S01] 我们甚至突破了结构化数据的限制，进入了能够理解人类模糊意图的多维向量空间。所有的这些令人惊叹的底层架构，说到底都是在读与写，存储与速度之间，
[S01] 精确与模糊之间寻找最完美的权衡
[S02] 了解这些，不仅能让作为学习者或开发者的你，在面对各种技术选型时不再迷茫。更重要的是，它赋予了你一双透视眼
[S01] 一双透视眼
[S02] 让你在未来的每一天，当你滑动手机查询数据，或者向AI提出疑问的那一瞬间，都能看透这块玻璃屏幕背后那套精密庞大且时刻运转的数字宇宙。你看到的将不再只是结果，
[S02] 而是整个宇宙的呼吸
[S01] 没错，说得太好了。最后留给你一个或许有些疯狂，但基于我们今天讨论的向量嵌入自然延伸的开放性问题
[S02] 哦，什么问题
[S01] 我们今天讲了，现代数据库可以通过AI把文档、图片，甚至人类语言的意义转化成多维空间中的一串浮点数，通过距离来检索相似度
[S02] 是的
[S01] 这不禁让人思考，如果在未来，随着脑机接口的发展，连我们人类微妙的情绪，我们最深处的记忆，甚至是一段只可意会不可言传的个人经历，都能被精准地嵌入到一个几万维的向量空间里。到那时候，
[S01] 我们在所谓的数据库里检索出来的，还会仅仅是我们今天理解的冰冷信息吗
[S02] 还是说当我们输入一个查询，它能直接为你检索出，并让你瞬间重新体会到某一种似曾相识的感觉。期待你的思考。本次深度解析就到这里，
[S02] 我们下次再见。